uh what year do you think we'll have a
super intelligence
I don't know I mean that's pure
speculation I think it's uh I think it's
very clear just taking a step back that
we had a big breakthrough in the last
year yes right where the the llms and
diffusion models basically reached a a
scale where they're able to do some some
pretty interesting things and then I
think the question is what happens from
here and just to paint the two extremes
on the
um
on on one side it's like okay we just
had one breakthrough if we just have
like another breakthrough like that or
maybe two then we could have something
that's truly crazy right and and is like
is um
just like so much more advanced and and
on that side of the argument it's like
okay well maybe we're
um
maybe we're only a couple of big steps
away from uh from from from reaching
something that looks more like general
intelligence
okay that's one that's one side of the
argument and the other side which is
what we've historically seen a lot more
is that a breakthrough leads to
um
you know in that in that Gartner hype
cycle there's like the hype and then
there's the trough of disillusionment
after when like people think that
there's a chance that hey okay there's a
big breakthrough maybe we're about to
get another big breakthrough and it's
like actually you're not about to get
another breakthrough you're maybe you're
actually just gonna have to sit with
this one for a while and
um and you know it could be
it could be five years it could be ten
years it could be 15 years until you
figure out
the um the kind of the next big thing
that needs to get figured out and um
but I think that the fact that we just
had this breakthrough
sort of makes sense that we're at a
point of almost a very wide error bars
on what happens next yeah um I think the
traditional technical view or the like
looking at the industry
would suggest that we're not just going
to stack
in a like Breakthrough on top of
breakthrough on top of breakthrough like
every six months or something right now
I think it it will I'm guessing I would
guess that it will take someone longer
in between these but um
I don't know but I tend to be pretty
optimistic about breakthroughs too so
I'm inside I think if you if you if you
normalized for for my normal optimism
then then maybe it would be even even
slower than what I'm saying but but even
within that like I'm not even opining on
the question of how many breakthroughs
are required to get to general
intelligence because no one knows
but this particular breakthrough was so
such a small step that resulted in such
a big leap in performance
as experienced by human beings that it
makes you think wow are we is as we
stumble across this very open world of
research where we stumble
um across another thing that will have a
giant leap in performance
and also we don't know exactly at which
stage is it really going to be
impressive because it feels like it's
really encroaching on impressive levels
of intelligence
you still didn't answer the question of
what year we're going to have super
intelligence I'd like to hold you to
that no I'm just kidding but is there
something you could say about the
timeline
as you think about the development of
um AGI super intelligence systems
sure so I I still don't think I have any
particular Insight on when like a
singular AI system that is a general
intelligence will get created but I
think the one thing that most people
in the discourse that I've seen about
this haven't really grappled with is
that we do seem to have
organiz organizations and you know
structures in the world that exhibit
greater than human intelligence already
so you know one example is a you know a
company you know it acts as an entity it
has you know singular brand
um obviously it's a collection of people
but I I certainly hope that you know
meta with tens of thousands of people
make smarter decisions than one person
but I think that would be pretty bad if
it didn't
um
another example that I think is even
more removed from kind of the way we
think about like the personification of
of um of intelligence which is often
implied in some of these questions is
think about something like the stock
market where the the stock market is you
know takes inputs it's a distributed
system it's like the cybernetic organism
that
you know probably millions of people
around the world
or basically voting every day by
choosing what to invest in
but it's basically this
this organism or or structure that is
smarter than any individual that we use
to allocate Capital as efficiently as
possible around the world and
I I do think that
this notion that there are already these
cybernetic
systems that are either melding
the intelligence of multiple people
together or melting the intelligence of
multiple people and Technology together
to form something which is
dramatically more intelligent than any
individual on the in the world
um
is something that seems to exist
and that we seem to be able to harness
in a productive way for our society
is as long as we basically build these
structures and balance with each other
um so I don't know I mean that that at
least gives me hope that as we advance
the technology and I don't know how long
exactly it's going to be but you asked
when is this going to exist I think to
some degree we already have
many organizations in the world that are
smarter than a single human and and that
seems to be something that is generally
productive in advancing humanity and
somehow the individual AI systems
empower the individual humans and the
interaction between those humans to make
that collective intelligence Machinery
that you're referring to smarter so it's
not like AI is becoming super
intelligent it's just becoming the uh
the engine that's making the collective
intelligence is primarily human more
intelligent
yeah it's educating the humans better
it's making them better informed it's
um making it more efficient for them to
communicate effectively and debate ideas
and through that process just making the
whole collective intelligence more and
more and more intelligent
maybe faster than the individual AI
systems that are trained at human data
anyway are becoming maybe the collective
intelligence of human species might
outpace the development of AI
so there's a balance in here because I
mean if if like you know if a lot of the
input that
that the systems are being trained on is
basically coming from feedback from
people
then a lot of the development does need
to happen in human time right it's it's
not like a machine
will just be able to go learn all the
stuff about about how people think about
stuff there's there's a cycle to how
this needs to work this is an exciting
world where we're living in and that
you're at the Forefront of developing